okay
illegal migration Bill Lord Murray of
Bloodworth
yeah
I beg to move that the bill will be now
read a second time
my lords
the British people are generous and
welcoming
to those in need fleeing persecution war
and humanitarian crisis abroad
they also know
that uncontrolled illegal migration
makes us less safe
is unfair on taxpayers
puts lives into the hands of people
Smugglers
and is unfair on would-be immigrants who
play by the rules
over forty five thousand people came
here by small boat last year
the overwhelming majority of arrivals
were adult males under the age of 40.
my lords these Journeys are extremely
dangerous
people have lost their lives attempting
to cross one of the world's busiest
shipping lanes
in a flimsy boat
these Journeys are also unnecessary
those making the crossings are coming
from safe countries such as France where
they could have claimed Asylum
our broken Asylum system is costing the
country some 3 billion pounds a year
and taxpayers are now spending over 6
million pounds a day on hotels alone
we cannot continue year on year with
this Relentless rise in the number of
illegal arrivals
adding unacceptable pressures
not just on our capacity to house new
arrivals
but also on our ability to provide
Health educational children's and
Welfare Services
my right honorable friend the prime
minister is right
we have to stop the boats
and I welcome the fact that this
objective is shared across the political
Spectrum
the issue today before your lordship's
house is how best to achieve this shared
objective
my lords there is no one single solution
we need to address this complex issue
across a broad front
and this bill needs to be seen in its
wider context
this government has already delivered
the largest ever small boats deal with
France
a new agreement with Albania a new
unified small boats operational command
tougher immigration enforcement
new more robust measures for identifying
potential victims of modern slavery and
a plan to clear the Legacy initial
decision Asylum backlog by the end of
the year and move migrants out of
expensive hotels
to my lords we also need new legislation
to make it unambiguously clear
that if you enter the UK illegally you
will not be allowed to stay here
instead you will be liable to be
detained and will be swiftly returned
either back to your home country or to a
safe Third Country
by removing the incentive to come to the
United Kingdom that we will stop people
taking these dangerous Journeys and
deter the people Smugglers from
profiting off people's suffering
this is what the bill seeks to deliver
crucially my lords the bill places a
legal Duty on the Home Secretary to make
arrangements for the removal of illegal
entrants who meet the four conditions
set out in Clause 2 of the bill
this is critical to the operation of the
scheme
it will send a clear message about
parliament's intent in enacting this
legislation
stupid save in the very limited
circumstances provided for in the bill
it will be crystal clear to Illegal
migrants the courts and the British
people
that the Home Secretary is legally bound
to remove all those who meet the
conditions set out in Clause 2 of the
bill
as soon as it is reasonably practical to
do so
as I have indicated the exceptions to
this Duty will be limited and in most
cases only temporary
in particular we recognize the
sensitivities in relation to
unaccompanied children
that is why the bill provides that the
duty to make arrangements for removal
does not apply until they reach
adulthood
which in some 70 of cases is within two
years of their arrival
but reflecting our current policy the
bill confers a discretionary power to
remove unaccompanied children in limited
circumstances
the bill now expressly sets out those
limited circumstances in which the power
to remove unaccompanied children may be
exercised that is for the purpose of
reuniting a child with a parent where
the child is to be returned to a safe
country of origin or where the child has
made no protection claim
the bill also suspends the duty to make
arrangements for removal
again on a temporary basis in the case
of those persons who make a factual
suspensive claim or a serious harm
suspensive claim
it is vital to the effective operation
of the scheme provided for in the bill
that we address head-on the cycle of
repeated and late legal challenges by
those seeking to frustrate the home
secretary's existing removal Powers the
suspensive claims provided for in the
bill
will be the only claims that will be
heard in country
and will therefore be the only route by
which someone can challenge removal
legal challenges by way of judicial
review are of course still available
but they will not suspend removal and
Clause 4 of the bill makes this clear
these claims can continue remotely
it follows from this that the courts are
not able to Grant any form of interim
relief which would have the effect of
holding up removal pending consideration
of the substantive judicial review
Clause 52 now makes this clear on the
face of the bill
my lords as I have indicated
the bill itself makes provision for two
kinds of suspensive claims which provide
sufficient legal remedies to those
seeking to challenge their removal
where a person seeks to challenge their
removal on the basis that the Home
Secretary has made a mistake of fact in
deciding that they met the removal
conditions they can Lodge a factual
suspensive claim
where such a claim is successful the
duty to make arrangements for removal
would no longer apply
although the claimant may be subject to
enforcement action under existing law if
they have no legal basis to remain in
the United Kingdom
the second type of suspensive claim is a
serious harm suspensive claim under the
provisions of the bill a person who has
made a protection or rights-based claim
in respect of their home country will
not be returned to that country unless
it is one of the safe countries listed
in new section 80 a a of their
nationality immigration and Asylum Act
2002.
and then only if there are no
exceptional circumstances militating
against their return
but such a person can and will be
removed to a safe Third Country
serious harm suspensive claims recognize
that exceptionally there may be a
well-founded reason why a person can't
be removed to a particular Third Country
specified in the removal notice
such a claim must be based on the fact
that a person would face real imminent
and foreseeable risk of serious and
irreversible harm if they were removed
this is purposefully a high bar and one
that reflects the terms on which the
European Court of Human Rights may
decide to indicate interim measures
under rule 39 of the rules of Courts
where is serious harm suspensive claim
is upheld it would be open to the Home
Secretary to remove the person to
another country or to revisit their
removal to the original Third Country
following a change of circumstances for
example
should the medical condition which
previously prevented removal
subsequently improve
my lords I have already alluded to the
fact
that the test for serious harm
suspensive claims reflects the approach
taken by the Strasbourg Court when
deciding the grant of interim measures
I have also explained that the
provisions in the bill placing
limitations on the grant of interim
remedies by our domestic courts
in this context it is entirely right
that we should address the impact of any
interim measures indicated by the
Strasbourg Court
my Lord's claws 53 of the bill provides
for a discretion for a minister of the
crown to suspend the duty to remove a
person wear an interim measure has been
indicated
that discretion must be exercised
personally by a minister
this means the minister May suspend
removal in response to a rule 39 into a
measure but is not required to As a
matter of UK law
the Clause provides a broad discretion
for the minister to have regard to any
factors when considering whether to
disapply the duty
and provides a non-exhausted lifts list
of considerations
that the minister may have regard to
when considering the exercise of that
discretion
as my right honorable friend of the
immigration Minister indicated in the
House of Commons this government takes
our International treaty obligations
incredibly seriously and I can assure
Noble laws that this discretion would be
exercised judiciously and on the basis
of the facts of an individual case
my Lord's moving on the bill provides
for bespoke powers of detention for the
purpose of the scheme
it is vital that we have the power to
detain to establish whether a person
falls within the scheme and pending
their removal
if the bill is to be effective both as a
deterrent and as a means of ensuring
that the Home Secretary can comply with
the duty on her to make arrangements for
removal
that said
I again acknowledge the particular
vulnerability of unaccompanied children
that is why the government has brought
forward amendments
to provide that unaccompanied children
may only be detained in circumstances
prescribed in regulations
in addition in line with the commitment
given by the immigration Minister we
will set out the new time scale under
which children may be detained for the
purposes of removal without judicial
oversight later in the Bill's Passage
through this house
my lords it is a central tenet of the
bill that a person who satisfies the
conditions in Clause 2 of this bill will
not have their Asylum human rights or
modern slavery claims considered in the
United Kingdom
it is a sad but incontrovertible fact
that our modern slavery protections are
susceptible to abuse by illegal migrants
seeking to frustrate their removal from
the United Kingdom
whereas in 2019 just six percent of
people arriving in the UK on a small
boat and being detained for return
involved a modern slavery referral
the figure in 2021 was 73 percent
the bill then
applies the public order
disqualification as provided for in the
Council of Europe convention against
trafficking
to those who meet the conditions in
clause 2.
this means that they will not benefit
from the protections otherwise afforded
to potential victims of modern slavery
the bill provides for an exception where
a person's presence in the UK is
necessary for the purposes of their
cooperation with a law enforcement
agency in the investigation of an
offense linked to their exploitation
we recognize that the application of the
public order disqualification to this
cohort is a significant step and only
Justified during such time as the
exceptional circumstances relating to
the illegal entry into the UK including
arising from the channel Crossings in
small boats continues to apply
it is for this reason that the modern
slavery Provisions are subject to a sun
setting Clause such that unless renewed
by affirmative regulations agreed by
both houses
they will cease to apply after two years
my laws as I have set out the whole
point of the bill is deterrence
as well as being clear that illegal
entry into the UK May simply result in
your detention and Swift removal the
bill also underlines that you will have
no ability to build a life in the UK
save in very limited circumstances
Clauses 29 to 36 of the bill provide
that a person will have no right to
secure settlement acquire British
citizenship or once removed lawfully
re-enter the UK
finally let me return to the theme I
began with
ours is a welcoming compassionate and
generous Nation
we have offered we have offered our
homes and communities to nearly half a
million people seeking protection since
2015. we have safe and legal routes
available to people from any country in
the world such as the refugee family
reunion scheme the UK resettlement
scheme as well as in recent years
country specific routes for people from
Syria Hong Kong Afghanistan and Ukraine
We Stand ready to do more
but our ability to do more order must be
directly linked to our capacity to house
and support new arrivals
we recognize the calls for early
progress on this front so within three
months of Royal Ascent we will begin the
consultation with local authorities and
communities themselves to understand
their capacity to accommodate and
support persons to be admitted to the UK
each year through safe and legal routes
and within six months of Royal Ascent we
will set out in a report to be laid
before Parliament the existing and
proposed additional safe and legal
routes and we will seek to open the
proposed new routes as soon as
practicable
and in any event by the end of 2024
my lords we simply cannot continue with
the situation whereby year on year tens
of thousands of people make the
dangerous illegal and unnecessary
journey across the channel in
circumvention of our immigration
controls
illegal migration is not fair and it is
not right
and it is not fair on the British
communities whose public services and
housing are under pressure
it is not fair on those who work hard
and obey the law to come to the UK
through established roots
and it is not fair on the people
traveling in the small boats themselves
who are placed in Peril at the hands of
the people Smugglers
we must stop the boats
this bill in conjunction with the other
steps the government is taking is a
necessary
urgent and indeed compassionate response
to the daily challenge posed to the
Integrity of our immigration system we
must act now and on that basis I beg to
move
the question is that this bill been over
at a second time Amendment Lord Paddock
yeah my Lord so I beg to move the motion
standing in my name on the order paper
Trevor Phillips recently wrote in the
times that in
2175 million people lived outside the
country of their birth and that by 2020
it was going to be 200 it was 280
million
he likened the prime minister's pledge
to stop the boats to King commute
ordering back the incoming tide
he argued that we need to bring order to
the flow rather than focusing on the
impossible task of locking the doors to
keep Asylum Seekers out
we agree
we have yawning gaps in our labor
markets that refugees could fill
we believe we should adopt the approach
many other countries are adopting
that responsibility should be taken away
from the home office and given to the
foreign office or the department for
business and trade
that migration is no job for the Home
Secretary
Phillips agrees
my lords we should be harnessing the
power of the incoming tide not refusing
to accept that it cannot be stopped
the government talks about pull factors
we talk about push factors
the Intolerable conditions in their home
countries that compel Asylum Seekers to
find Sanctuary elsewhere in the world
even in detention in the UK you don't
have to worry about where you're going
to live how you're going to survive
without adequate food or water
whether you're going to be killed
persecuted or otherwise have your life
endangered
can the minister say what evidence the
government has that the measures in this
bill will deter Small Boat Crossings
talking of so-called pool factors the
government has reduced its spending on
measures designed to improve conditions
in Asylum Seekers home countries from
0.7 to 0.5 percent of gross national
income
while at the same time spending millions
of pounds from that 0.5 of this
so-called overseas aid on housing Asylum
seekers in the UK
can the minister confirm how much less
the government is spending currently
spending on overseas early since the
downgrade to 0.5 percent and how much of
the 0.5 percent is being spent on
housing Asylum seekers in the UK
my Lord's the Home Secretary in the
times today talks about and I quote the
clear desire of the British people to
control immigration yeah
the telegraph reported yesterday that in
the year to December 2022
there were one million 370
000 work study or other visas granted by
the government to allow people to come
and stay long term in the United Kingdom
under the telegraph headline net
migration to hit double
pre-brexit level
the Home Secretary says the number
seeking Asylum across the channel in
small boats in the same period was forty
five thousand
just over three percent
of those who sought to stay in the UK
last year
even if every Asylum Seeker was granted
leave to remain
if the government as it appears to be is
subscribing to subscribing to the
populist view that there is quote too
much immigration
can the minister explain why it is
attempting to push through legislation
that seeks to deter only three in every
100 long-term arrivals
and why since brexit it has increased
the number of countries from which
people can enter the UK without question
and without a Visa by 10.
my lords the government portrays Asylum
Seekers as an undesirable drain on
society
we disagree
let me give Noble Lords an example
a young man who I know personally who is
now in Norway has been had been living
in Afghanistan when at the age of three
he lost his father killed in the
Afghanistan war and at the age of five
his mother died of breast cancer
he was sent to his grandmother in Iran
where he worked from the age of six
until he was 12. he saved enough money
to begin his journey through Europe
finally arriving in Norway the day
before his 16th birthday
where he was granted Asylum
never having been to school before
arriving in Norway at the age of 23 he
now speaks fluent Norwegian and English
he works long hours in the security
industry sending 500 pounds a month to
his grandmother grandmother and his two
cousins in Iran
he is also on a three-year course at
police College
that will result in him becoming a
Norwegian police officer
he has a Norwegian passport and driving
license he lives alone in a private
rented accommodation that he pays for
himself and he is saving for a deposit
to buy his own home
as well as paying Norwegian tax and
National Insurance
under this bill if he came to the UK in
the same way he would face compulsory
x-rays to confirm that he was not an
adult
even though the home secretary's duty to
deport him would not apply until he was
18 the secretary of state would still
have the power to deport him whilst he
was a child
he would most likely be detained until
he was 18 and then sent to Rwanda even
if anyone if anyone ever gets sent to
Rwanda and even if the capacity of
Rwanda could cope with the numbers
involved
during that time the home office could
prevent him being looked after by a
local Authority
ignoring this country's International
obligations to act in the best interests
of the child and the provisions of the
part three of the children's Act
whether the Detention of Asylum Seekers
was reasonable or not including
Detention of children pregnant women and
victims of torture
potentially indefinitely would no longer
be a matter for the courts to decide but
for the Home Secretary
if the European Court of Human Rights
blocked his deportation by means of an
entering order the Home Secretary could
ignore the judges ruling
UK courts would be prevented from
granting an injunction even if they were
grounds for a judicial review
so much for the rule of law
if he could not be sent back to where he
came from because neither Iran or
Afghanistan are listed as safe countries
and he remained in the United Kingdom
he would never be able to work never be
given leave to remain never be able to
become a British Citizen and neither
would his children were he to have any
and neither would any of his family
members
estimates are that between 160 000 and
193 000 Asylum Seekers could be left in
limbo in the United Kingdom in the first
few years of the operation of this bill
a permanent drain on the state a
subclass of society opened to labor and
sexual exploitation
can the minister say when we will
receive the government's own impact
assessment or will Noble laws have to
rely on NGO estimates
and this young man's story is not
exceptional there are many such examples
in the UK that prove that those with the
drive and determination to make such
long and perilous Journeys are just the
sort of people who will work hard
positively contribute to society and
support their families the complete
opposite of hack to how this government
seeks to portray those seeking Asylum
my laws this bill seeks to
systematically deny human rights to a
group of people Desperately Seeking
sanctuary
this bill would breach uh International
obligations under the U.N conventions of
refugees the rights of the child the
reduction of statelessness and the
European convention against trafficking
this is the first but not the only Bill
that explicitly states that the bill
does not have to be compatible with the
European convention on human rights
the Human Rights Act is being revoked
one law at a time
this bill would undermine the rule of
law with ministers being able to ignore
the rulings of judges and at the same
time my lords we are asking Russia and
China to abide by International rule of
law
one final thought my lords I studied
moral philosophy at University
one of the acid tests for whether
something was morally right or not was
the question
what would happen if everyone did the
same thing
can the minister say what would happen
if every country country adopted the
approach outlined in this bill
my lords this bill is a low point in the
history of this government
and we should not allow this bill to
proceed any further my lords I beg to
move yeah
the original question
the original question wasn't this bill
be now read a second time since when an
amendment has been moved to leave out
from that to the end and insert the
words as printed on the order paper
the question I therefore have to put is
that this amendment be agreed to
uh my Lord before I make my speech let
me make clear uh with regards to the
amendment that we will not support Lord
paddock's motion of course we oppose
this bill and did so at second and third
reading in the other place we understand
why the amendment has been put and we
know it sounds attractive but if we did
all that would happen is the government
would use the parliament act where no
amendments is in this place would then
be possible
so we will propose amendments and press
the government to think again but we
recognize that the elected house passed
this legislation but can I also say to
the minister and so to this chamber we
don't need lectures either from the Home
Secretary or the Justice secretary about
the Constitutional position of the Lords
we won't be rushed or intimidated into
giving the bill an easy ride we will do
all we can
to do our job in seeking support across
the chamber to bring about the much
needed change that is needed
my Lord says we begin this house this
discussion of the bill can I declare my
own interest it's an unpaid Trustee of
the human trafficking foundation and the
work I do at the University of
Nottingham rights lab but I believe it's
essential if not crucial that we lay out
a game the principles upon which we
should base our consideration of the
measures contained in the bill we can
address the detailing committee and that
reports but I will do so and I will do
so a little in the speech but what of
our principles so of course we Face a
very real challenge with the government
having lost control of migrants crossing
the channel in particular an asylum
policy in general this bill is the
latest response to a crisis where 138
000 Asylum claims await decision where
forty five thousand seven hundred
migrants crossed the channel in 2022
with
6415 so far this year oh my Lord since
this bill was announced 300 to
3265 migrants have crossed the channel
some deterrents and they come into
assist them we're already 38 900 people
are awaiting removal so of course
there's a problem that needs fixing but
this new bill layering more incompetence
more complexity more unworkability and
more unfairness won't do it it'll make
it worse indeed it comes less than a
year after we were told that it would
all be sorted out by the nationality and
borders act that that was the answer
that was the solution and that was the
way to stop the boats the ink is hardly
dry on that and in blind panic as the
pro problem gets worse new measures
which would have been regarded as
Unthinkable just a few years ago are now
to be rushed through so in the face of
increasing global migration fueled by
Regional insecurity war and persecution
a challenge that with climate change can
only get get worse where is the
leadership that you would expect from
our government our government says our
solution is to go It Alone embarrassed
and humiliated even as we look at
countries often some of the poorest
countries in the world taking hundreds
of thousands of refugees from conflicts
on their borders one only has to look at
Sudan where are the leaders like
Churchill and Tory MP Maxwell Fife who
set up the Council of Europe when faced
with the humanitarian and Refugee crisis
post-world War II obviously now is
totally different but they saw
International cooperation based on human
rights as an essential prerequisite for
any solution this illegal migrants Bill
condemned by the United Nations Refugee
commissioner by the Council of Europe by
UNICEF and by numerous ngos and
organizations including Faith
organizations working in this area
condemned by all and what does the
government condemn as out of touch
lefties trendy lawyers people who aren't
in touch when I say standing up against
those who are introducing unworkable
measures that drive a stake through the
heart of our International standing is
something that we can be proud of as
amnesty says the bill under Clause one
will mean that whatever the merits of
the refugees Asylum claim whatever the
strength of their connection to the UK
and however in however indecent or in
Practical the aim of expelling them is
their expulsion is to be required by
this bill and no moral no legal or no
practical consideration is to obstruct
that I say that is shocking and
appalling furthermore then the bill asks
anyone any Court from interfering it
says no judicial view for up to 28 days
for anyone no no ability to test the
legality or reasonable reasonableness of
that under Clause 2 to be allowed are my
lords under this bill everyone has to be
detained who has entered irregularly no
matter no matter answer if you're
fleeing persecution war or being
trafficked you will be locked up
thousands upon thousands to be locked up
but the government won't even give a
number there are approximately two
thousand places available at the moment
how many more cruise ships military
barges or camps are needed where are
they when will they be available no idea
the government has no proper plans the
government has clueless and no judgment
can be made as there is no impact
assessment available to us to consider
to consider and my laws we have no idea
what happens after that 28 days all of
it predicated on returns agreements like
Rwanda which is stuck in the courts and
again with other such agreements being
completely non-existent and what does
the government do it seeks to undermine
the echr unilaterally even while it
negotiates with them by giving the Home
Secretary what is effectively an opt-out
from any interim measure granted under
rule 39 by the government
us join a cherry MP the acting chair of
the jchr reminded us we are talking of
the suspension of measures such as
extradition not stopped but suspended
while a case is properly examined my
lords she pointed out that between 2019
and 2021 interim measures under rule 39
were applied for in 880 cases against
the UK but granted in just seven how
does that justify driving a coach and
horses through International treaties we
signed an indeed helped set up as the
former Attorney General Jeffrey Cox MP
said the provisions in this bill ask the
house should it be approved to allow
quite deliberately and consciously a
deliberate breach of Our obligation
under the convention and what of
children in this bill particularly
unaccompanied children last year over
5242 unaccompanied children saw asylum
in the UK these children will be
detained whatever the minister says for
an uncertain period of time and returned
if possible even if allowed to remain in
the UK while a child unaccompanied
children will live in the knowledge that
on their 18th birthday they will be
subject to removal regardless of their
protection needs which will be deemed
inadmissible if this bill becomes law
more children will go missing
notwithstanding the children's act
unaccompanied children I've often been
placed in hotels outside the care system
the result has been 4 600 children
placed in home office run hotels
440 missing episodes and 200 children
still not found my lords this bill will
make it worse and I say to the
government if the state was a physical
parent it would be prosecuted Clauses 15
to 20 do all of the above and have been
condemned by amongst others to
children's condition commissioner
Clauses 21-28 destroy one of the
conservatives governments greatest
achievements destroy the legacy of
Theresa May a former prime minister and
destroy our reputation as a world leader
in the area of modern slavery it drives
as the former prime minister said a
coach and horses through the 2015 modern
slavery act my lords if you haven't read
Clause 4 1C they cannot claim to be a
victim of slavery or trafficking to
suspend any detention or removal
Justified that justified based on
selective statistics as Theresa May the
former MP for the former prime minister
said buy this bill more people will stay
enslaved and it will give more power to
the slaves and traffickers don't think
of trying to escape because if you do
you will be sent away perhaps to Rwanda
this can't be what our country has come
to and again the government has said you
don't even have to be in the UK to
insist and in the investigation making
it harder to identify catch and
prosecute the traffickers most
astonishingly of all said by the former
prime minister to be and I quote a slap
in the face for those of us who actually
care about wishes of modern victims of
modern slavery and trafficking my lords
that was a former conservative prime
minister in the other place just
recently saying that about the
provisions contained within the modern
slavery uh sorry before the in the
illegal migrants bill before us today so
we have a bill that gives the Home
Secretary the power to remove anyone who
arrives via an irregular reap with no
certainty as to where
uh if anywhere such a power extends to
Children the power to children with uh
with no legal redress for at least 28
days immoral but there is no space for
detention no places courts can be
ignored whether domestic or
International no returns agreement no
International cooperation and no help if
you are trafficked that's what this
house is being asked to support my laws
a new approach is needed there is a
better way an approach which takes on
the traffickers and Smugglers one which
sorts out the bureaucratic mess with a
fast-track Asylum system and model of
the current Asylum system and one that
that seeks International agreements and
cooperation an approach which would also
see a restoration of the aid budget to
0.7 tackling more problems in the region
itself and the Speedy setting up of safe
and legal routes but above all my laws
is an approach which is workable which
is practical and based on our
International obligations and
conventions that we have signed instead
in response to a broken system that is
failing we have a government playing
fast and loose with our place in the
world and our respect for international
law this must change and we on Earth we
will do all we can particularly at
report to change this bill not by
blocking it but to stand up for those
who look to us for sanctuary and
proposing workable Humane Solutions and
we will be proud to do so asking the
government to think again as is the
constitutional rights of This House of
Lords to do with respect to things that
come to us from the other place we will
not be cowed by the other place in
trying to intimidate us into saying that
that you seek to change it of course we
will seek to change it of course we will
seek to amend it of course we will say
that we where we think the government
has got it wrong that has always been
what this house does and we will not be
deflected from that as I say it needs a
different approach a moral approach
approach one that works not one that
will make it worse but I think what we
see from this this government is even
more gimmicks no chance anymore more of
the same is what we'll get until we get
the change that we need and that the
country needs which is a change of
government
yeah well done
my lords I wish to acknowledge that the
outset
the great assistant I have received in
discussions with doctors children the
Barrister with particular expertise and
experience in immigration law
it's important to appreciate where we
are going on UK legislation on refugees
there are four resettlement schemes
operated by the United Kingdom
Syria Afghanistan Ukraine and Hong Kong
critically under the immigration rules
there is no Asylum Visa route for an
individual Refugee to enter United
Kingdom and claim Asylum
this means that unless a person is
within one of the four resettlement
schemes
or Asylum is taught by someone already
lawfully present in the United Kingdom
the refugees arrival and entry to the
United Kingdom will inevitably be
illegal
this will mean that they will fall
within Category 2 States Refugee status
under the nationality and borders act
they are therefore subject to
accelerated and punitive procedures and
even if they fulfill the refugee
definition will not have the benefits of
settlement and nationality offered to
group one refugees
they would however be able to make a
human rights claim or a protection claim
albeit under strict constraints
including very short time limits
if they have arrived after the 7th of
March 2023 it also means that they will
almost inevitably be caught by the four
conditions for mandatory removal under
Clause 2 of the bills presently under
consideration
it is obvious and must be emphasized
that this is not a small boat Bill the
provisions of this bill would affect all
of those who seek Refugee status in this
country and are entitled the protection
of the 1951 convention
yeah
in a move away from even The Limited
rights of Category 2 refugees under the
2022 act the duty under Clause 2 of the
bill to make arrangements for their
removal is unaffected by the making of a
protection claim or a human rights claim
or an application to judicial review
any protection claim or human rights
claim is by Statute inadmissible and
Carries no right of appeal
removal must be to one of the countries
specified in schedule 1. but the only
country there specified with which the
United Kingdom has an arrangement for
taking such Asylum Seekers is Rwanda
such Asylum Seekers will be detained as
provided in Clause 10 and that will be
under Clause 11 for such period as the
sector of State considers is reasonably
necessary to enable the removal to be
carried out there is no statutory time
limit on such detention
an asylum Seeker is subject to removal
underclaws 2 does have the ability to
make a suspensive claim either a serious
harm suspensive claim or a factual
suspensive claim but that does not
affect the legality and finality of the
obligation of the selective state to
make arrangements for removal
can it get any worse for a refugee
seeking asylum in the United Kingdom
it can because even in relation to safe
and legal routes that's the full
resettlement routes close 58 of the bill
says the secretary of state must make
regulations
specifying the maximum number of persons
who may enter the United Kingdom
annually using such safe routes
even in the case of refugees from war or
armed conflict the government has failed
to provide a safe route in relation to
Sudan
we appear to be witnessing the playing
out of a policy Continuum under which
increasing barriers of refugees United
Kingdom are being imposed with an
ultimate goal of preventing all refugees
save those who have already applied
under the full resettlement schemes
it's against that background that I wish
to illustrate the operation of the
current and proposed legislation by
reference to LGBT refugees
it is well established that LGBT
refugees are within the protection of
the refugee convention
that is not only the view of the unhcr
but has been decided by our own Courts
at the highest level
unless an LGBT person is already
legitimately in the United Kingdom and
claims Refugee status while here or
happens to be within one of the four
resettlement schemes they will as I've
said almost inevitably be called by the
four conditions in Clause 2 the bill and
so the sector state will be under
statutory duty to make arrangements to
their removal
they cannot make a protection claim or a
human rights claim or make an
application for judicial review to
prevent the operation of that Duty
they will be detained for as long as the
sector State considers reasonably
necessary to enable the removal to take
place without any strategy limited time
and none of that is affected by the
ability to make a serious harm
suspensive claim
they have to be sent to one of the
countries in schedule one
here however is a difficulty
there are many countries on that list in
schedule one
which have anti-lgbt laws or where even
if such laws are not actively enforced
or there are no Express laws there
exists a social environment where there
is anti-lgbt persecution with impunity
and a climate of fear for LGBT people
this is particularly true of those
commonwealth countries of which there
are many where our Colonial history has
had the civilizing consequence of
bequeathing brutal anti-lgbt laws and
prejudices
such laws of prejudices exist in the
following countries specified in
schedule one
Albania Brazil particularly in relation
to trans people Gambia Ghana Hungary
Jamaica Kenya Liberia
Malawi Mali Mauritius Nigeria and Poland
Rwanda Sierra Leone and in some respects
South Africa
the only country which the
time United Kingdom has reached
at the end
the foreign the foreign office travel
advice includes the following
homosexuality is not illegal in Rwanda
but remains frowned on by many LGBT
individuals can experience
discrimination as abuse including from
local authorities there are no specific
anti-discrimination laws that protect
LGBT individuals
so while the search is on for some other
more appropriate safe country for LGBT
refugees fleeing persecution which may
take years or never be achieved the
refugee is detained without limit of
time what an appalling indictment of our
failure to comply with our International
legal obligations in breach of the rule
of law under a lack of humanity and
empathy
[Music]
my lords we need a bill to reform
migration
we need a bill to stop the boats we need
a bill to destroy the evil tribe of
traffickers the tragedy is that without
much change this is not that bill
this bill fails utterly to take a
long-term and strategic view of the
challenges of migration and undermines
international cooperation rather than
taking an opportunity for the UK to show
leadership as we did in 1951.
there are too many problems for one
speech in this bill and
the right Reverend pellets the bishop of
a direham and Bishop of Doster will
speak to other issues
but I hope the government will listen to
the speeches today pointing out some of
the issues including the eloquent and
detailed speech by the noble Lord Lord
Coker
the existing Global conventions and
agreements need updating
in response to the crises we face today
while now inadequate what those
conventions offer is a baseline from
which to build a globally shared
understanding of what protection must be
given to refugees
they are not inconvenient obstructions
to get round by any legislative means
necessary
legal compatibility is a question for
the Learned lawyers among your Lordships
but it does not require a lawyer to see
that what is suggested is a dramatic
departure from what was ever envisaged
in international law since 1951. even if
this builds succeeded in temporarily
stopping the boats and I don't think it
will it won't stop conflict or climate
migration
the ipcc
forecasts that climate change by itself
let alone the conflicts it's already
causing will lead to at least 800
million more refugees
a year in total by 2050.
and what if other countries follow suit
the unhcr has warned that the bill could
lead
to the collapse of the International
System that protects refugees is that
what we want the United Kingdom's
contribution to be in our leadership
currently 80 percent of refugees are
still in the global South protected by
the poorest countries in the world
of course we cannot take everyone and
nor should we
but this bill has no sense at all of the
long-term and of the global nature of
the challenge that the world faces
it ignores the reality that migration
must be engaged with at source as well
as in the channel as if we as a country
were unrelated to the rest of the world
it is a siled bill not a whole of
government bill it does not draw in
Conflict Management and prevention which
drives migration it does not draw in
climate impacts which Drive migration
and conflict it is isolationist it is
morally unacceptable and politically
impractical to let the poorest countries
deal with the crisis alone and cut our
International Aid
nor is there any measure in this bill
for engaging with the criminal gangs of
traffickers directive directly and
offensively rather than trusting simply
to what appears to be the
unpredictability of Market forces as if
traffickers were rationally trained
economic actors and not appalling
criminals
there must be safe legal routes put in
place
as soon as illegal unsafe routes begin
to be attacked we cannot wait for the
years that will take place before that
happens
my lords this bill is an attempt at a
short-term fix
it risks great damage to the UK's
interests and reputation at home and
abroad let alone the interests of those
in need of protection or the Nations who
together face this challenge our
interests as a nation are closely linked
to our reputation for justice and the
rule of law and to our measured language
calm decision
and careful legislation
none of those are seen here
long term globally coordinated Solutions
must be part of the way forward
this nation should lead internationally
not stand apart
I intend to table amendments at
committee stage which encourage this
longer-term thinking and collaborative
Focus including a plan for combating
traffickers and working with
International Partners to look at
updating the 1951 convention
nevertheless
I hope that this house will not support
Lord paddock's
excellent sympathetic and carefully put
Amendment
I agree with its sentiment but I also
believe that as though kokara said it is
our duty to change not to throw out the
bill
and finally as one might expect from
these benches
in the New Testament in Matthew chapter
25 Jesus calls us to walk welcome The
Stranger
that call has been part of the history
and culture in this country for
centuries and was part of the drive for
the modern slavery Act
I urge the government to reconsider much
of the bill which fails to live up to
our history our moral responsibility and
our politically our political and
international interests
it is indeed a privilege to follow the
noble and most reverent climate and I'm
sure the whole house would wish to
congratulate him on the most
distinguished part he played in the
coronation proceedings on Saturday
about my Lord's notwithstanding the
eloquence of those who have previously
spoken in opposition to the bill I
cannot agree with them I support the
bill
it is the first duty of a government to
protect the borders of its state and the
bill represents the best available means
of achieving that objective
I shall make three points
first I want to deal with the allegation
that the provisions in the bill
particularly those relating to interim
rulings of the European Court of human
rights in some way breached the rule of
law
secondly I want to comment on the
provision of safe routes for Asylum
Seekers and thirdly I want to consider
the extent to which the biller's
measures are likely to succeed
my Lord's Day provisioned provisions of
clause 53 have attracted a good deal of
controversy and it's been suggested that
they constitute a breach of our duty
under the European convention and
therefore a breach of the rule of law
in order to assess the validity of these
arguments it is necessary to examine the
legitimacy of the power of the European
Court of human rights to make interim
rulings which is what Clause 24 is all
about
close 53 is all about
the European Court derives its Authority
from the convention
article 46 of the convention expressly
states that only final judgments of the
Court are binding
and Rule 39 of the Court's rules of
procedure which provides the basis for
its ability to make interim rulings
states only that it may indicate the
measures that it thinks should be taken
in any case
it is true that the court in a case in
2005 seemed to conclude that it could
make a binding interim ruling
but that was clearly inconsistent with
the convention and with rule 39 itself
against that background that is
considered the ruling which the court
made last year in relation to the
government's plan to remove illegal
immigrants to Rwanda
it was an ex-parted ruling
so the UK government had no opportunity
to State its case
it was issued by an anonymous judge in a
press release
and it was indefinite in the sense that
no provision was made for a hearing to
take place at which the UK government
could State its case
it was contrary to all the rules of
natural Justice I ask your Lordships to
consider the Fate on appeal of any first
instance judgment in our courts which
was made in that way it wouldn't survive
five minutes
the response to that lamentable State of
Affairs set out in Clause 53 is
commendably moderate it gives a minister
of the crown discretion and in
sub-clause 5 it sets out some of the
matters to be taken into account in
exercising that discretion those matters
represent all the elements of natural
Justice which were lacking in the
interim decision made by the court last
year
so I commend Clause 53 to your Lordships
next I'd like to say a word about safe
routes
there are of course legitimate arguments
to be made about safe routes
but they are I'm afraid
irrelevant to the need for measures to
deal with the baits let me explain why
unless everyone and I mean everyone
who applies for leave to there to enter
the UK through a safe route is granted
that right there will be some who are
refused
and some of those who are refused will
be able to acquire the means to pay the
people's Smugglers
and the people's mugglers will continue
to put them on boats to cross the
channel
so whatever the arguments in favor of
safe and legal Roots they are a repeat
and relevant to the main provisions of
the bill
finally my lords I want to say something
about the likely efficacy of the
measures set out in the bill
now can in my view be little doubt that
the most effective way of dealing with
the problems posed by the illegal
immigrants crossing the channel
is to reach a return agreement with
France we reached such an agreement in
1995 when I was home secretary
both countries agreed to take back
anyone who invented one country from the
other and who was refused admission
and although the numbers refused
admission to the UK far outnumbered
those applying for and refused admission
to France
France honored and complied with the
agreement which as a matter of fact has
never actually been rescinded or revoked
but I accept that France is not now
prepared to implement this or any
similar agreement so the government has
to take whatever action is available to
it it seems to me that this bill
represents the best option available to
it I believe it will have a deterrent
effect and diminish the ability of the
people's Smugglers to continue to play
their evil trade
and I commend it to the house
my Lord it is a privilege to be able to
take part in this debate and given the
the attendance in the house today and
the number of speakers and the number of
ngos who've contacted us with
representations about the bill there's
clearly a great deal of public interest
in the bill and quite a lot of it is in
support of the opposition to the bill my
Lord I was listening to the minister
very carefully when he made his opening
remarks and I'm not sure I've got the
word in quite quite accurate here but he
said this government takes International
obligations seriously and then he
proceeded to explain why that was not
the case
there are so many instances now where
the minister was forced as it were to
eat his words because we've for a long
time valued the international
consensus on human rights including
refugees we felt that this was a part of
the world we wanted to be in it was
healthy it was sensible it was humane
and when countries have torn up
that particular approach we've condemned
them properly and we know who they are
but my lord for the minister to say we
take these obligations seriously and I
we're not going to invade Northern
Ireland but it was it was the third
about some normal matters as well
my Lord it is fundamental to the
reputation of this country as I think
the uh the most relevant climate made
very clear it is fundamental to the
reputation of this country that indeed
we take a clear stand on human rights we
set standards and the need for too long
the world has followed us well not too
long for a long time the world has
followed us I was with the joint
committee on human rights in Strasbourg
some time ago
visit visiting the European Court of
Human Rights and at that time there was
some talk about this country not
adhering to a decision of the European
court on on the voting rights for
prisoners in in jail
but what they said to us this has been
was this they said Britain has a
reputation for adhering to decisions
made by the European Court of Human
Rights you've stuck by the European
convention and if you do not then the
notorious abusers of Human Rights will
simply say well if the United Kingdom
doesn't do it why should we and that's
already beginning to be the case and
we're we're beginning we're beginning to
hear that and it is very clear that the
United Nations High commission for
refugees the medic statement I think
we've all probably seen it but let me
hold this from a small part of it the
effect of the bill in this form would be
to deny protection to many Asylum
seekers in need of safety and protection
and even deny them the opportunity to
put forward their case this would be a
clear breach of the refugee convention
and would undermine a long-standing
humanitarian tradition for which the
British people are likely proud now if
the United Nations had commission to
refugees says something is a bit of a
convention surely they are the guardians
of the uh of the refugee convention and
it's not up to the governments to say
well we don't like this bit of it and
and we don't we know we don't intend we
don't intend to we don't intend to get
to go along with it well there's so many
ways in which our Refugee system is a
massive moment
we've had it referred to in earlier
debate earlier speeches by my by my
another friend Lord Coker for example
but yet
bill is tackling virtually none of those
we have an enormous backlog of Amazon
cases anybody sitting in Calais will say
well look the can't even with all
these cases are 150 130 150 000 of them
and the home office are not capable of
making any decisions so look let's have
a go let's have a go because they won't
make a decision about us either
well the government talks about return
agreements now I welcome the fact that
the prime minister went to France and
discussed this with the French Authority
something we've long been asking for
but the fact is there is no return
agreement in place with any country
other than uh well the render will not
be a return again but there's no return
agreement in place if the minister could
indicate where sexual agreement exists
then maybe some of the things he said
will force that into place I was very
concerned about what he said about
judicial review and I'm sure there'll be
amendments to this effect but if I
understood him correctly what he's
saying is that judicial review will be
much more limited than in the past and
we've always seemed to this review as a
fundamental safeguard
uh
the reference will be made to the rights
of children and the minister says well
we
will held them here until 18 and then we
can remove them
but previous governments have said no
children will be treated in a more
humane way but no that that appears no
longer no longer could be the case
and as for safe routes I know that I
know there are NovoLog have preceded me
uh said he didn't think safe foods safe
and legals would work but I'm sure that
it is right that whether I think the
neighborhoods and the people sitting in
Cali elsewhere will try and use them
they have done so they have done so in
the past well it's just vaporating when
I say this and I think uh Noble Lord and
Overlord has already referred to it but
but the humanists have in fact gone
attention to the list of 57 countries
which is said to be safe and and the
humanist International report found that
10 of those have on book prison
sentences to a blasphemy and apostasy
and many of these are enforcing these
laws and significantly Nigeria is one of
those countries and that maintains the
death penalty for blasphemy and indeed
the president of the Nigerian humanist
Association is serving 24 years in jail
for blasphemy so that is not a country
which is safe to say safe
all those small Boat Crossings will not
be dealt with by this by this build I
feel they won't and lastly can I say
this there is an argument that we must
get public opinion on our side
publicly matters and some of the
language used by some government
ministers is intended to inflame public
opinion and make public opinion make
public opinion hostile to refugees
rather than to enable us to assume our
tradition of welcoming people who are
fleeing for safety to our Shores
well it's what an absolute pleasure to
follow the noble Lord dumbs who's a
living example of what happens when a
country opens its Hearts to refugees and
how those people then can then settle
here and contribute to the Future
prosperity of the nation that they make
home
my Lord this bill has already failed in
its primary purpose set by senior
government leaders it failed on Thursday
when the results from the red and blue
wall seats came in and they demonstrated
that this Bill had not delivered
conservatives the votes that they sought
from this bill this is not a bill to
deal effectively sensitively and
humanely with those seeking Refuge via
unofficial Roots there is nothing such
as an illegal route there are unofficial
routes into the UK sometimes in very
dangerous situations that could cause
the loss of life this bill is highly
political and has got nothing to offer
in getting rid in getting rid of the
backlog of Asylum claims has nothing to
offer to effectively deter and deter the
real criminals those who traffic and
profiteer from the desperation and
misery of those seeking asylum in the UK
or really being effective in building a
coalition of international Partners to
work across the globe to deal with this
this bill for the Home Secretary is
about trying to win votes in some
parliamentary seats by using language
that dehumanizes people and using
traumatized and vulnerable people as
political pawns my lords the government
says that this bill is about stopping
the boat which it will not and because
of that this house has a duty to stop
the bull b-u-l
the government itself hasn't a clue how
this will all work out because if they
had they would have published an impact
assessment they know that if they had it
would expose the false nature of their
proposals and the claims about what the
bill will achieve one third country
Rwanda has signed up to this deal via
offshoring the UK's obligations to
process and settle those who seek asylum
in the UK Rwanda will be able to take a
maximum of only a few hundred people in
the next few years the government can
make a wishlist of third countries and
put it on the face of the bill but it
means nothing no other countries have
signed up and the government knows that
they are light years away if ever from
getting there to having enough third
countries to take the number of people
that will be seeking asylum in the UK
via unofficial routes
that will therefore lead to many
hundreds of thousands of individuals
stocking limbo in new home office
Refugee prisons as no other options are
available under this build
so where are the vulnerable and
traumatized individuals going to be
imprisoned by the home office
these home office Refuge prisons have to
be identified commissioned and in some
cases built whether they float or on
Terra Firma it will cost a taxpayer an
extra six billion pounds in the next few
years according to the refugee Council
for these places in Practical
inexpensive and inhumane that is not how
a proud and decent country deals with
those fleeing War torture and rape
how you deal with the most vulnerable
says a lot about the values of the
government of a Nation
the government has chosen to treat
unaccompanied children seeking Refuge
some will have seen their parents killed
acts of War being sexually exploited and
trafficked here to the UK as criminals
not worthy of having the dignity hope
and opportunity to rebuild their lives
and settle here in the UK under the bill
children can be detained at the home
secretary's wish and for as long as she
sees fit a child version of refugee
prisons it is entirely unclear how the
power set out on the bill will sit
alongside the local Authority's Duty
under Section 17 of the children's act
1989 to safeguard any children in their
area and take them into care under
Section 20 if the criteria for so doing
are to be met the bill has the potential
to make it harder for local authorities
to fulfill their duties in the children
Act
in relation to ensuring stability for
children as their cooperate their
corporate parent and to protect and
support child victims of traffic in
exploitation
if a child is lucky enough to reach to
be in the care of a local Authority
until the age of 18 and has the
protections of the look after status in
law just what awaits them on their 18th
birthday imagine a traumatized and
vulnerable child who arrives to the UK
aged eight spending 10 years building a
life here a network of support and
Friends educated here knowing nothing
but a life in the UK then for the
government to snatch that all away from
them and throw them out of the country
to God knows where at the age of 18. do
does the government not understand how
impractical and inhumane this is
inhumane as thousands of young people
getting near to 18 will just disappear
many into the hands of criminals and
traffickers impractical as those who are
in Practical as we're back to those
third
imaginary third countries who will not
be waiting with places to take these
individuals so they will be left in
limbo in an adult home office Refugee
prison my lords this bill is inhumane in
Practical and ineffective it's built on
the ridiculous premise that the only way
to stop the traffickers profiteering is
to criminalize their vulnerable victims
and treat them in a way that is subhuman
my lords this bill undermines our
commitment to international law our
obligations under the U.N treaties for
the refugees and for the child it
degrades what it means to be British
this bill trashes our proud and
long-held values in record dating back
to 1951 on how we deal with those
seeking Asylum it undermines our
country's International standing for
upholding and abiding by international
law it's for these and many other
reasons that this bill has no place on
the statute Booth it must be placed into
the Dustbin of history as soon as
possible and that is why I will be
supporting my Noble friend Lord
paddock's fatal motion to ensure that
this bill does not pass this second
stage
my lords it is a clever ploy to entitle
this bill illegal migration bill
Not For the First Time illegal migration
has been conflated with Asylum
this is essentially an asylum Bill an
asylum is a fundamental right and
migration of course is a choice
and while the government claims that
this bill is designed to deal with both
people the bill will apply to everyone
who arrives here by whatever means as
from 7th of March 2023
and it is doubtful if the bill will
achieve his objectives it will probably
make matters worse and damage our
reputation internationally
my lords no one denies that action is
needed
but what we want to see is an effective
Fair compassionate Asylum system which
respects our International obligations
and rule of law
Asylum is a collective responsibility of
all states a global challenge which
requires International cooperation
working within Regional and
international Frameworks achieve
effective and sustainable results
this cannot be done in isolation
and what we need is a system which
ensures that all claims are considered
efficiently and speedily no matter what
the mode of travel
this requires streamlined processes and
tailored Asylum sieges
we need expansion of safe and legal
routes to ensure that those suffering
prosecution can reach UK safely without
being exploited by Smugglers
and we need to support those seeking
Asylum so they engage effectively with
processes integrate and contribute by
being able to work here
this bill Falls very short of these
objectives
in fact several amendments introduced
during the report stage in the other
place will make will will raise the bar
even further
they will have the overall effect of
making it even harder for people subject
to the duty to remove them from the UK
to resist removal
it would raise the threshold of for a
person to show that they would suffer
serious harm
and with regard to new Clauses regarding
age assessments the government itself
has identified this Clause as one which
it was unable to State as compatible
with the convention
and another Clause identified as one
which could not be declared to be
compatible with the convention is the
one which gives immigration officers due
powers to search for seize and retain
electronic devices such as mobile phones
from individuals who are liable to be
detained under the bill to access copy
or use any information
remained
seriously concerned that the bill risk
place in UK in the breach of this
International obligations to protect
human rights and exposing people to
Serious harm particularly measures for
the Detention of children pregnant women
and removing protections for victims of
trafficking and modern slavery
and the bill itself starts with the
statement that that the minister is
unable to say this its Provisions are
compatible with with the conventions
my lords the bill in effect will block
almost everyone who arrives here by
means which the home office deems
irregular by making admissible Asylum
claims by making the claims of people
who have entered arrived in the UK by
irregular means permanently admissible
it also makes nearly all those people
unremovable in reality despite facing a
duty on the Home Secretary to remove
them if they meet certain conditions
this will create a large and permanent
population of people who will live in
limbo at public expense for the rest of
their lives without any hope or securing
lawful status for those who may be
removed the Third Country there will be
a new complex fraud Fast Track system
with limited edition scrutiny to make
claim that suspense removal
it is predicted that this bill will
result in a large number of people being
detained
for victims of modern slavery who are
Target for removal the bill removes
almost all protections leaving them at
the mercy of traffickers this bill in
fact strengthens the hand of traffickers
and the bid is equally damaging for
children
what is missing from the bill or any
specific proposals for safe and legal
routes to enter the UK the bill contains
no confirmed details of any additional
routes even with the amendment at the
report stage in the other place there is
no obligation the bill to create create
new routes
there's nothing about speeding up
processes of of processing of claims
decision making is slow and the backlog
is increasing
and as we know the bill has been
condemned by a whole range of people
and the European home Affairs
commissioner and the council for Europe
commissioner for human rights have
raised seed is concerned that if the UK
were to withdraw from the HCR the EU
could terminate the law enforcement and
judicial cooperation in criminal matters
part of the UK EU trade and cooperation
agreement as this agreement allows EU to
suspend or terminate the agreement as a
whole if there is serious and
substantial failure by the UK to respect
human rights and human rights treaties
to which both are parties my Lord what
makes worse is the rhetoric which has
accompanied this this
bill which damages what billion stands
for hostile language which demonizes and
humanizes those seeking seeking Asylum
and refugees Grace resentment and
apprisals equally damaging other tax on
on lawyers and of course this house
these attacks highlight the government's
inability to respond to substantive
concerns raised by this bill and clumsy
comments that values of those seeking to
come here are at odds with the values of
this country are not helpful my lords it
is not the values of those seeking
Asylum here which are ads with the
values it is this bill which is at odds
with the values of our country
I'd like to concentrate my remarks if I
may on Lord panic's Amendment which I
think is a complete abuse of this house
this house is here to revise and offer
advice to the elected House of Commons
and for any member of this house to
bring forward an amendment that seeks to
kill a bill completely which has been
passed by majorities of around 60 in the
other place and which is an absolute
priority for the prime minister to stop
their boats is an absolute abuse and I
didn't think any member of this house
who respects the values of this house
and its role could possibly go through
the lobbies and vote for that Amendment
the point of course of this bill is to
stop the votes now I have listened very
carefully to the speeches that have been
made and I have yet to hear a remedy
from anyone who opposes this bill as to
how we are going to stop the boats I
hear a lot about the rights of children
and the rights of people fleeing
persecution much of which I support but
I count support the idea of people
drowning in the English Channel fleeing
from a safe country which is France
to be drowned in the English Channel and
watch your children
being taken by the Sea must be the most
horrendous experience and yet all the
people who are opposing this bill have
nothing to offer by way of a remedy for
that problem which is happening now and
which will happen in the course of the
following weeks as the summer as weight
of it
to the neighborhood I think if the naval
law were to look at Hansard for December
11th you'll find a whole day debate on
immigration which puts forward some very
very clear ideas about stopping the boat
Earth most reverent primate and I Echo
the words of my Noble friend about what
a fantastic job he did on on Saturday
and I I am in strong agreement where
where he is where he is concerned with
issues spiritual rather than temporal
and I use the word and I use the word
temporal in this sense because of course
there are many things we can do but
these are all going to take time people
are drowning in the English Channel now
people are leaving a safe country in
order to come here and it is uh factuous
to try and present this as in the way
that many have done I I mean I the much
uh misquoted uh often attributed to
um Edmund Burke but it was actually John
Stuart Mill who said bad men need
nothing more to Compass their ends than
good men should look and do nothing and
that is what we are hearing today
effectively that we should do nothing
about the immediate problem now to
return to the amendment the rule the
rule of this house
the role of this house is to give advice
and make amendments and I accept that
there are issues with this bill that
need further scrutiny particularly the
issues of those people who are already
here in the United Kingdom and who are
victims of slavery who are placed in a
position where they are unlikely to help
the police and to help those who are
concerned to deal with the villains here
the real villains here are the
traffickers and the men and women who
exploit uh people under enormous stress
and strength and it is just not
reasonable to criticize the the
government for trying to deal with this
problem I mean how on Earth can it be
justified that 40 000 albanians are able
to come to this country uh and and to
argue that that is something that should
not be tackled by Crossing from France a
safe country into this country which is
able to and also those people who
criticize uh the values of this country
need to ask themselves why do so many
people want to come here rather than to
remain on the uh at the other side of
the channel in France and we need to uh
it has been suggested that we we we are
that the perhaps hubris is set in as a
result of the success of the Liberals I
call them liberals because it is not
liberal Democrats and not Democrats who
seek to use an unelected house in order
to overturn the decisions which have
been made by an elected house the fact
is we know perfectly well that the
United Kingdom has got finite capacity
our public services are under immense
strain and the notion that we should be
spending billions of pounds and not
actually addressing this problem of
stopping the boats so I say to those who
oppose the bill by all means improve the
bill but to support such an amendment
I'm delighted that the official
opposition have indicated they will not
do so and indeed the right Reverend
premise has said the same but we need to
recognize that something needs to be
done and it needs to be done now and
this is something which is an
alternative to doing nothing which is
the oppression of the people opposite
before before the noble Lord sits down
if I may just ask what I was going to at
a more timely manner the the noble the
most noble Prelude the primate the the
Archbishop did ask you a question as to
whether the noble Lord was aware of the
Practical proposals that had been made
in a previous debate he did not answer
that question and I think the house
would like to know
uh to the noble Lord who for whom I've
got immense respect of course I'm aware
of the measures but I thought I did
point out
um when I said uh that those would take
time of course it's it's possible to
argue for changes in our approach of
course it's possible to argue that it's
necessary to to use overseas aid uh in a
way to uh support people in their own
countries I get all of that but there is
an immediate problem now and this bill
deals with it and it's a duty upon this
house to get this built on the statute
back so that we can deal with what the
terrible things that are happening in
the English Channel
Lords I refer to the register and
support from Ram Here We Go Again The
Wretched of the earth fleeing violence
of persecution or to be thrown from the
frying pan of nationality and borders
act into enacted less than a year ago
Into the Fire of this punitive and
inhumane bill which effectively raises
and no Asylum Seekers hear sign at our
border
moreover it will have retrospective
application just one example of how the
bill undermines the rule of the law
the bill has serious implications for
groups in especially vulnerable
circumstances despite the limited
concessions in the Commons the
children's commissioner who feels
passionately about this warns the bill
would I quote place the UK in clear
breach of its international law
obligations under a range of children's
rights treaties
clear legal restrictions on children's
detentions introduced by the
conservatives are withdrawn
uh restrict restrictions on
rights concerning age assessment are
circumscribed contravening the
recommendations of the
government-appointed advisory committee
and future citizenship rights are lost
yet still no sign of a child rights
impact assessment
can the novel or the minister therefore
explain how the Home Secretary will meet
her duty to safeguard and promote the
welfare of children under Section 55 of
the borders citizenship and Immigration
Act 2009 the importance of which to this
bill is underlined by UNICEF among
others
furthermore the restriction on the
Detention of pregnant women that the
government conceded in 2016 in response
to successful amendments in this house
will be removed with serious health
implications for mother and baby
my lords at the heart of the bill is
what the unhcr describes as an asylum
ban such a ban it makes clear
contravenes the refugee convention and
international human rights law
in the Commons a former prime minister
Theresa May wander the damage this could
do to our International reputation
the unhcr also warns that the bill does
not guarantee more safe and legal routes
on the contrary it places in an
inflexible annual cap which includes
children on the numbers admitted this
way moreover it makes clear that welcome
as they are such Roots can never
substitute for the right to claim Asylum
in the Commons the Home Secretary
described as fatuous claims that the
bill breaches Refugee convention
obligations can the minister explain why
we should accept the government's
interpretation of the convention over
that of the body with super advisory
responsibility for it describe the other
day in this house as a key partner
and in the absence of adequate Third
Country agreements could you explain
what will happen to all those deemed
inadmissible who can't be returned to
their country of origin under the
convention because they claim will not
have been assessed the fear of the
refugee Council the unhr CEO and others
is that they will be left in
semi-permanent limbo at risk of
destitution the likely harm to mental
health is spelled out by the Royal
College of psychiatrists
my lords the Bill's title is phrased so
as to Signal the false claim that
desperate people who cross the channel
in boats or enter via other or
unauthorized means or economic migrants
yet analysis of official data indicates
that 6 out of 10 who crossed the channel
last year would be recognized as
refugees
in contrast the home office has been
unable to provide evidence to back its
representation of them as economic
migrants
instead as already noted ministers are
deployed vile dehumanizing language such
as Invasion breaking in and cannibalize
in order to create fair and hostility
amongst the British people undermining
the very social cohesion they claim to
be promoting all in the name of
compassion
the significance of such language is
brought home by Earthen an asylum Seeker
in the preface to a recent Jrs UK report
on Napier barracks
he writes how he came to realize and I
quote these are not just words they
build a completely new identity which
then justifies how you'll be treated
seen and talked about the language that
dehumanizes people makes it seem
acceptable to place them in inhumane
conditions and cut off from society such
words he warns stigmatize and justify
discrimination my lords there can be no
justification for such language nor can
this shameful Bill be justified as the
wide range of civil Civil Society
organizations briefing us so well have
made clear
rush through the commons and still
awaiting the required impact assessments
we have a heavy responsibility in this
house to scrutinize and amend it from
start to finish I hope we will fulfill
that responsibility and protect the
fundamental right to claim Asylum
my lords I decided to speak today after
reading the words of the immigration
Minister Robert generick speaking for
the government to policy exchange
demonizing migrants and failing to
recognize our responsibilities to
refugees seeking Asylum let me quote him
excessive uncontrolled migration
threatens to cannibalize The Compassion
that marks out the British people
cannibalize what a deliberate and
demonizing choice of word
I quote again
those Crossing tend to have completely
different Lifestyles to those in the UK
undermining social cohesion deliberately
decisive language and certainly not
borne out by the UK experience and
throughout that speech the constant
failure to look separately at economic
migration from Asylum seeking
I am the daughter of a refugee
my mother was born into an Orthodox
Jewish Family in a small village in
eastern Hungary
when the Hungarian government brought in
anti-jewish laws in 1938
she and her family tried to obtain visas
to go to another country but like so
many others found that no visas were to
be heard
she decided to be a survivor
she became a nightclub dancer in order
to join a truth going on a tour in the
Middle East
once outside Hungary she settled in
Greece which she hoped to make her home
but by 1943 the beginnings of Civil War
in Greece were tearing apart Athens her
bed was strafed with bullets friends
standing beside her was shot down in the
street
women's bodies lay butchered women with
particular targets
she had met my father a major with the
British Army in Greece but he was denied
Army person to marry her and his
attempts to get her papers to go to
Britain were rejected
he returned with his regiment to the UK
and was demolved
so you can imagine his astonishment when
on Christmas Eve 1945
he got a call from an air base in
Southern England
to say that my mother had arrived on a
British military plane from Continental
Europe
she had been smuggled on board by the
RAF
she was a genuine Refugee but no one
could argue that she had chosen an
official route or as this government
would call it a legal route this
government would send her to Rwanda as
an undesirable
my lords I want to ask the minister
today to show me that body of evidence
and I see the minister and is no longer
in his place so I asked perhaps the
whips and others would put the point to
him because I do want an answer but uh
um I want the minister to show me that
body of evidence and research that shows
how British compassion has been
cannibalized by Asylum Seekers and by
people like my mother and me
I want to see his evidence of damage on
cohesion the genuine Asylum Seekers
never mind migrants have inflicted on
the UK I suspect we will find it has no
substance
he needs to show why diversity is a
weakness not a strength
ironically if the government continues
to argue that migration creates such
problems it should never by its own
logic return a single Refugee to any
country that already has a significant
migrant population and that eliminates
most of Europe and indeed Africa
including Rwanda
now limiting economic migration has
never required treating Asylum Seekers
as undesirables
I argue for the Britain that we saw this
weekend at the coronation not threatened
by diversity but energized by it and
comfortable with its complex identity
I recognize that not all the children of
migrants or refugees share my view
so Ayla bravaman the Home Secretary the
daughter of migrants asserted in the
Commons on immigration that we have had
too much of it in recent years
but many do share my view
and say do to others what I would ask
you to do for my family
and I repeat to the minister who has now
returned to his place
put in front of us today the evidence of
the damage that you claim that underpins
and justifies this bill and without
which it should not stand and indeed
please feel free to use my mother and me
as your examples
yeah
there's a few situations are so bad they
can't get worse and certainly the
current world migration crisis
inevitably will get worse whether the
unhcr is bigger for those currently
needing free settlement is 100 million
or just tens of millions uh future
floods fars famines uh human conflicts
inevitably you've got to drive it up now
obviously it's insoluble by any single
country so and this is the easy point to
make there must be International
agreement as to what share of the burden
we must all take of course we must make
the effort but let's not pretend it will
succeed it will and so each country like
the UK must find its own solution
including sensibly surely fuel dispute
deciding on a cap for admissions and the
best way for administering it now I'm
plainly this is by a range you can save
and legal routes for the number decided
on I'm plainly under the several schemes
currently operating the Ukraine Hong
Kong Syria Afghanistan family members
and so forth some are directly involving
unhcr others not proper consideration is
given an advance of arrival to who
should come
and now that we've absorbed uh so many
ukrainians and Hong kongers uh shorter
the time is right for a wider new scheme
ideally incorporate cooperation with
unhcr to admit more indeed uh this now
seems essential under a gen unless a
generous
fresh resettlement scheme is decided on
there's little hope of persuading people
to sign up to these obviously severe
measures happily there are most of this
country still hugely sympathetic are to
refugees
um
how infinitely preferable would this be
to the present chaotic situation uh of
having to process those arriving after
Paris boat on Lorry Crossings as to
these ones entitled to ask why should
they steal a market in an advantage over
those we will have agreed to take under
the CAC schemes surely it can't be
suggested we should reduce the number we
agree to take lawfully under these
schemes to accommodate those coming by
boat and although I don't accept that
those arriving from a safe country like
France or Belgium are not on that ground
alone
disqualified for Refugee status having
indeed myself in decades past judicially
decided the contrary there's no reason
to ignore the fact that their lives were
not in an immediate danger when they
took to the boots they had the money to
pay the Smugglers and in a number of
cases actually had already been refused
to saw them in France or plainly had no
legitimate claim uh either to Asylum as
most of the albanians at the core of
this bill therefore necessary in either
twin aims of introducing and enforcing a
cat for the numbers we take in future
and deterring all others from arriving
illegally by ensuring that with only the
narrowest exceptions they gain
absolutely nothing from doing so
my laws will need a basic uh
justification for that already I have
time for claim that the bill raises many
different and difficult questions on
children accompanied and unaccompanied
about whether or where and for how long
to detain those coming illegally about
Rwanda about modern slavery about
article 39 interim orders about the
existing backlog etc etc but there is no
time to discuss those today no doubt the
bill can be improved in various ways but
we must recognize that almost every
Amendment we make to soften the bill can
only attend to weaken its essential
objectives stopping the votes and the
real desire of many sometimes perhaps
masked by an avowed concern about deaths
in the channel on are limiting overall
numbers are admitted I think we really
must know Harden our hearts and give the
government the opportunity by this bill
finally to confront this most
intractable problems I hope not to lose
too many of my friends by saying
something
my Lord um
a pleasure to follow the noble Lord
Brown
we're told that this bill is unethical
which puzzles me because like my Noble
roommate Lord Forsyth
um I can't quite get my mind around the
ethical nature of this bizarre
proposition
that
unelected parliamentarians
should without any real discussion
destroy a bill that has been passed by
our elected House of Commons
and for which there is very considerable
public support
but hey ho
I find this bill in many ways
distasteful I wish we didn't have to
have it
but the issues it tries to resolve are
supremely distasteful
actually they're barbaric
we need action
but the bill is Full Of Weeds we're told
well if there are weeds in the garden
and knowing modern legislation there are
probably a good few
pull them out
you replaced them you don't call in a
cement truck to cover the entire thing
in concrete to bury it as this fatal
motion demands
at its heart my lords this bill aims at
finding a better moons of fighting the
modern slavers and people Smugglers
saving innocent lives and that seems to
me to be a most moral objective
it aims to stop that evil trade in human
beings by these Smugglers and the
slavers
and it is only by beating them
by crushing them if we can that it will
put an end to the miseries and deaths
we've all seen too often on the Seas and
if we don't act if we lose control of
our borders we play straight into the
hands of the racists and the bigots who
will stir up hatred on our streets and
in our communities
there are terrible consequences to be
paid if we fail in this
so
how do we stop those who are right here
claiming to be children
with stubble on their chins
who have deliberately destroyed all
their documentation
who've paid thousands of pounds to
people traffickers which enables those
people traffickers to continue their
awful trade
these people these Pretenders if you
will are the enemies of genuine refugees
because they are helping create and
sustain a system which is evil
run by criminals of the cruelest kind
who think nothing of
throwing children overboard to drown in
order to save their own miserable lives
they trade in lies they trade in lives
and it is our moral obligation to stop
them
to bring an end to the
unimaginable pain of mothers and fathers
watching their children drowning off our
Shores in the channel
and no amount of hand-wringing or bell
ringing is going to do that
now I know that the labor party at
second reading in The Other Place said
it wants to Boost International policing
to
try to catch the Smugglers
well let's hope they can
catch the drug traffickers too while
they're at it
they know that that is not a solution
and this exotic and deeply
unconstitutional proposal to kill the
bill
in my view is a moral cop-out
but there are no no no Simple Solutions
it's not just about small boats even
it's about jumbo Jets two it's about a
modern world in huge flocks
no
I wonder if the noble Lord would explain
how he and his snowball friend Lord
Forsyth
can tell me what were the uh
people thinking in this house when they
designed
A system that does allow for a fatal
motion when legislation is bad enough if
in 1946 the Salisbury convention was
considered absolutely adequate then that
is what we would have with no provision
for a fatal motion
let me try and answer the noble leaders
question about this um I wish that the
liberal Democrats would listen to the
arguments that will come at committee
and contribute to them rather than
trying to kill off all discussion that
to me is unprincipled and it is
unconstitutional
um
it's
this is a world in which there is no one
moral solution any more than there is
one legislative solution
and of course we will have to do more
much more
this bill is part of that effort so for
the doubters
what are your plans I don't want to
discuss them apparently but what are
your plans how will you stop the slavers
and the Smugglers what will you say to
the people of this country who have
their human rights too
but Lord if not this bill then what bill
what would you do
that's what we need to hear are not just
in
legis and we need to hear that in
legislative detail not just in passing
debate
we wait to hear the moral outrage that
we hear is matched with solid proposals
for action but I suspect that we might
be waiting from the opposition for a
very long time
so I want to start with
with Asylum Seekers
are and it's worth repeating of the
so-called safe countries in the bill at
least 10
have on book prison sentences but
blasphemy and apostasy
and as my Noble friend said the
president of the Nigerian humanist
Association Mubarak Butler is serving 24
years for blasphemy now you've got to be
a pretty nasty piece of work to support
that as a policy
but I want to go back to New labor I
know it's never popular with recent
labor leaders but between June 2001 June
2002 I was privileged to work under my
Noble friend Lord blunkett as the
minister for immigration citizenship and
nationality at the home office
I was responsible in sending people and
families who had arrived illegally into
the UK out of the UK
I was criticized by many including my
good friend Chris Mullen in one of his
many successful Diaries
but Chris did say I was operating the
law and the destination of such families
was the safe European countries from
which they had traveled to the UK and
indeed I can recall they included France
and Spain now I know it's become
unfashionable to praise new labor but it
Remains the case we were able to use the
doubling convention not massively but
from time to time to return people who
had no case to be in the UK from whence
they came
this Tory government this Tory
government ripped up the Dublin
convention when they organized and
controlled the brexit decisions
including getting rid of freedom of
movement it was a deliberate policy and
everybody knew Dublin would go without
any alternative in place
and as of today there is still nothing
in place why we hear constant talk of
popping across the channel meetings
between ministers but there's no
agreement
the present situation we're in is
entirely of this Tory government's own
making it owns brexit it owns the
actions of the coalition government
which I noticed by the way the world
started at 2015 today for the minister
it started for most of us at 2010 that's
when the Tories came into power
but it owns the actions of the coalition
government and it has left the UK
unsupported and friendless by our
Geographic Neighbors
and I can also recall the arguments and
briefings in the home office about why
the UK was a target for illegal
migration
other than the English language there
were and remain too
first the UK is the easiest European
country in which it's possible to work
illegally and second which helps the
first no identity system we in 2001 too
started work on the ID system in their
home office and it was pursued by others
after I had left and after my Noble
friend had left the home office it was
within sight of implementation when the
tory-led Coalition as one of its first
actions under the deal with the lib Dems
in 2010 was to scrap it the government
today owned that decision
of course it pleased the CBI and other
employer bodies as well as the Tories as
illegal working keeps wages down across
the economy That Remains the case today
new labor stuck to Legal Frameworks
which meant we could talk to our EU
partners and not become friendless and
indeed while it's not time to go into it
I can recall a couple of occasions when
the Civil Service had to warn us we were
on the verge of breaking the law
uh possible malfeasance was used so we
changed policy unlike the presentory
government who simply changed the
ministerial code
of course the roots then were the
channel tunnel via the lorries
we worked with the French including
visits the sanghat to seek to close
these routes safely
and finally we had a large backlog of
cases it was huge
the home office employed an expert in
operational research from the ministry
of Defense in fact I think
professionally he was a rocket scientist
who sorted out the flow of work in the
home office which vastly reduced the
caseload we were actively doing
something and we used external civil
servants but it were expert in making
sure that was the case so the government
owns the prison situation in its
entirety and has grown the caseload due
to incompetence
deliberately shunning friends and
breaking international law is not the
solution it's time for another new labor
government to sort it out
yeah
I lost this uh bill is a bill of
anachronisms anachronism is because it's
not suitable for our time and neither
does it reflect the values of our
country and it has consequences which go
far beyond the supposed effect of the
paper that this bill is written on
the bill starts with a statement under
section 19 of the Human Rights Act the
minister is unable to say that its
Provisions are compatible with the
rights contained in each echr and
express acknowledgment that the bill
puts human rights at risk however the
Secretary of State for home Affairs
stated in the Commons that she was
Commerce in vertical Commerce confident
and inverted commas certain that the
build measures are compatible with our
International obligations
so at the outset can the noble the Lord
the minister in when replying tell the
house whether the words on the front of
this bill are as a result of legal
advice to ministers and that the
certainty expressed by the secretary of
state is her view and not that of the
government's legal advice
I look forward to a reporter of the
joint committee on human rights which
would be very timely if we could see it
very speedily
secondly we're not offered any
assessment to accompany the bill
which of my Noble friend baroness
Bernice Crainer said was where's the
evidence
why was it that this bill could be put
together in such haste that it could not
be prepared is it because there's no
options in this bill and that it doesn't
matter it's an impact assessment but
given that the Bill's consequences will
require large amounts of money we are at
least entitled to know the impact it
will have on public finances and
resources
thirdly this bill sets up a substantial
shift of power from the courts to the
Secretary of State and from this
Parliament to the Secretary of State
the bill sets up the government as both
judge and jury in a court of its own
making
Clause won five of the bill this implies
Section 3 of The Human Rights Act
meaning that courts will no longer be
required to reprovisions and any
regulations the Home Secretary makes
under the extent of delegated ballot she
gives to herself in order for them to
verify their compatibility with
convention rights
and using as of now unknown legislation
the bill proposes giving the Secretary
of State very broad Powers which
Parliament will have no ability to alter
or to demand a government rethink
and my fast fourth concern I want to
illustrate by a story of Lynn
Lynn was trafficked into the United
Kingdom at the age of 15. she was
discovered by police in the back of a
lorry
Social Services placed her with a foster
family
where it was discovered that Lynn was
five months pregnant having been raped
by her traffickers
fortunately Lynn was able to move in
with the Foster family and give birth to
her son
under this bill Lynn would not be able
to use her status as a victim of human
trafficking to challenge her removal
and even if Lynn had passed to a safe
country she could not have claimed
Asylum there because she was held
prisoner by her trafficker
under this bill Lynn would not be able
to make a new life in the United Kingdom
for her and her son
and moreover the hand of Lin's captor
would also have been strengthened
because of this bill
they would have threatened that if she
tried to escape and contact the
authorities she would be removed from
the United Kingdom rather than be
provided with safety
the illegal migration bill would serve
the interests of Lynn's captors rather
than secure her rights
so here we are presented with the bill
which flaunts human rights legislation
deprives those seeking Asylum of their
right to have their case heard
a bill which amasses power to the
government from the courts in Parliament
and breaches are international
obligations
of course we are facing an issue which
requires a solution
but that
means working with our International
Partners including our partners in
Europe
there seems to me to be a fundamental
issue here
if the United Kingdom doesn't like the
treaties to which we are signed of if it
doesn't like the international
obligations to which we assigned them
then it should seek International
Solutions it should seek those
International Solutions which sit at the
heart of our International obligations
and not seek to try and find a route
which will have no success
this is a dreadful bill it's a Bill
built purely on political Dogma
it is unworkable
I have yet to meet anyone who believes
that it will achieve any of the aims it
sets out and it will leave tens of
thousands of people in limbo in this
country
it will bring misery to those who
genuinely have a case to ask us for a
place of Refuge
there are no safe routes and the the for
many of these people there are no roots
after this bill has been produced apart
from the very limited ones before it
and it is certainly the case that it
doesn't have to be like this there are
perfectly decent Alternatives perfectly
decent just and fair Alternatives
very good
plenty of time later to tackle the many
complications in this build
for my part I'm going to make a short
speech but I will take a longer View and
a wider View
it's now about 20 years since I
co-founded migration watch but with the
assistance of Professor David Coleman of
Oxford University
in that time
the population of the UK has grown by an
astonishing 8 million
that's about eight times the population
of Birmingham close to the population of
London
of this huge number nearly 7 million has
been due to immigration seven out of
eight that includes of course the inflow
of Asylum Seekers which is
been up and down over that period
likes to say this but it's truly obvious
that if this info is allowed to continue
the whole nature of our society will be
changed
not in our time but certainly in our
grandchildren's time
the government had claimed that their
new quote Australian style system for
immigration will get the numbers done
regrettably that is the exact opposite
of the truth
this government have actively encouraged
large-scale economic migration
I mentioned briefly three measures they
substantially reduce the educational
requirement
they're significantly lowered the salary
and they no longer require Jobs first to
be advertised on the domestic Market
as a result
nearly half of all full-time jobs are
now open to Immigrant labor
yes nearly half of all jobs six children
I lost it the current scale of
immigration of which Asylum is only a
small part simply cannot be allowed to
continue
the pressure on our schools and public
services is heavy and increasing
we already have to build
wait for it nearly 300 homes every
single day just to house immigrant
families
regrettably that is very seldom
mentioned in this house
that's a wider background to this bill
public anger at the chaos in the channel
has obliged this government to focus on
that appalling problem
but even at fifty thousand a year as
last year Asylum is only a small part of
immigration as a whole
when the numbers for calendar 2022 are
published in two weeks time we may well
find that net migration is running at 10
times the rate of asylum that is about
half a million it could be even higher
so my lords if this
Mass immigration is allowed to continue
it will very rapidly change the way of
life that we have developed over
centuries
it will also of course weaken our sense
of community as a society
the public census of course which is why
that nearly 60 percent of them want to
see immigration reduced
the bill that we're discussing today
may have some impact on one aspect of
mass immigration
however I repeat that Asylum however
chaotic is at present only a small part
of a wider issue
a real reduction in net migration
whatever its source is NOW essential to
preserve the nature of the country that
many of us love
declare my interests as a member of the
ramp project and the trustee of reset
when looking to engage with the bill
members decide whether to focus on the
detail or address the underlying
principles behind the proposed
legislation
this bill leaves me with no choice but
to start with the latter as it asks
fundamental questions about who we are
as a nation
in order to supposedly reduce Channel
Crossings are we really prepared to
consent to extinguishing as the UNH cell
puts it the right to claim Asylum and
withholding support for victims of
trafficking and secondly indefinitely
detaining thousands of Asylum Seekers
including children and pregnant women
we have been left to consider the bills
Provisions without an impact assessment
but these consequences will potentially
lead to an unjustified intolerable level
of harm which I would argue do not
reflect who we are as a nation
this bill appears to be fundamentally
about preventing those who have traveled
to the UK irregularly from claiming
Refugee protection
this is in clear breach of the refugee
convention and indiscriminately applies
to everyone regardless of the violence
or persecution they may have fled
let us be clear this means even refusing
to offer a child or a victim of
trafficking the Dignity of having their
Asylum case heard
more than three quarters of Asylum cases
assessed last year were found to be
valid
but under the new regime they would be
automatically deemed inadmissible
this bill conversely gives up on the
idea of returning people back home who
do not qualify for Asylum by grouping
them with those who would qualify and
attempting to remove them to a third
country
in reality both groups will be left in a
permanent state of legal precarity to
face a future of inescapable destitution
the home secretary's duty to detain and
remove Asylum Seekers changes the nature
of detention considerably
it moves it away from administrative
process to facilitate someone's removal
to a wider system of confinement
therefore it disturbingly does not
discriminate
the state will view a child or a
pregnant woman first and foremost as
individuals subject to immigration
control
not as an innocent child or a vulnerable
mother due to give birth
we need to ask what about the
government's duty to protect
just less than a decade ago the
conservatives introduced time limits for
the use of child detention and at the
very least I hope to see these limits
back on the face of the bill for all
children
a child faced with detention looks at
their surroundings and asks what did I
do wrong to be here
this develops into the question what is
wrong with me
we cannot let children face this trauma
as the children's commissioner for
England has said it is not acceptable
for them to be treated in the same way
as adults
safeguarding is not discretionary
while the bill enacts a new system of
detention it does not set any standards
inspection details or protective
obligations on the home office in terms
of accommodation
as I've said before children need the
highest levels of safeguarding written
into the letter of the law and I would
hope more detail was forthcoming from
the government on this
I'm reminded of Jesus words it would be
better to have a millstone around the
neck and be cast into the sea than to
cause a little one to stumble
this responsibility needs to Bear Upon
Us heavily
no one is questioning the need for
compassionate measures to prevent Asylum
Seekers having to resort to dangerous
Crossings to reach sanctuary but the
rationale behind proposing a cap on safe
routes while simultaneously penalizing
those who have no access to a safe
alternative is unjust
I do want to see the UK abdicate its
responsibility as a global leader to
explore Sustainable Solutions to force
migration in solidarity with the
persecuted
undermining the global system of refugee
protection is no solution
and it is beholden on us all to remember
that no one is too different and
therefore any less worthy of compassion
and respect
I hope our language in debate reflects
this truth
the wonderful founder of citizens UK
Neil Jameson sadly passed away recently
he often shared this quote it is not
hope that gives rise to action it is
action that inspires hope
it is this action I have seen
communities up and down this country
take as they have formed Community
resettlement groups open their homes to
Ukrainian refugees and supported Asylum
Seekers to build new lives and feel hope
again
the British people do support and help
those who genuinely have need
although there are strong feelings on
the issues this bill raises I pray as we
work together to bring a range of
amendments the legislation will better
reflect hope and a deeper Humanity
I always argue and indeed believe that
legislation is improved by the process
of scrutiny in this house
um but until the powerful and welcome
statement by the noble and learned Lord
Lord Brown of un Eaton under Haywood who
suddenly is no longer in his place I
thought no Noble Lords would be willing
to see how persistence against measures
in what some have described as popular
bills has the consequence of reciprocal
persistence
uh of yet stronger measures so I applaud
the noble and learned Lord Lord Brown of
Eaton under Hayward for his statement
and would urge other Noble Lords to uh
take note of what he said
that said I still urge my Noble friend
uh the minister who I commend
for the clear and sensitive way he
introduced this debate to listen
carefully to those Noble Lords who seek
with all sincerity to improve this
legislation with the purpose of ensuring
in its implementation it is effective in
stopping the boats that cross the
channel illegally
but as much as our Collective
Effectiveness relies on ministers
listening and taking this house
seriously it also relies on us your
Lordships listening and taking seriously
the public who demand that their elected
government take action against illegal
activity which affects their lives and
livelihoods
we often forget that as human beings we
all want what we often deny each other
respect and understanding
and in fact last night in this chamber
when we were debating amendments on the
Online safety Bill there was quite a bit
of frustration at uh the lack of uh
understanding uh from uh the government
in terms of
um its response to uh to to the debates
in that house
uh last night it's something which
frustrates many of our fellow citizens
is the ease with which we demand respect
and understanding for ourselves
and show it to those who we do not know
ahead of those we live alongside and who
support and cooperation we rely on most
whether we call them the squeeze medal
just about managing or the hard-working
people who play by the rules these are
the people we rely on to pay their taxes
keep good order in their communities and
uphold British values which we those of
us in leadership roles have become shy
or are reluctant to promote ourselves
our fellow citizens are no less
compassionate or caring dinners and they
too want to and do support people in
genuine need
but they don't want their compassion to
be taken for granted or taken advantage
of and they don't want us to dictate the
terms on which they must when it is them
who always have to pay whether that's by
the growing cues for public services
they have little Choice over using the
shortage of housing for them and their
families or through the consequential
changes to our society which challenge
people's sense of status at work and the
cohesiveness of their community
my lords I enjoy great privilege not
only do I spend a lot of time with
powerful and influential people in
Westminster and other walks of life and
get to hear and learn from their
experience and wisdom
again the same benefits of wisdom and
experience from my close family and
friends who ensure I also enjoy and
understand a very different world
unlike most of us some of them work
alongside immigrants from around the
world including people who arrived in
the UK on the backs of lorries a few
years ago
they too hear some tragic stories but
they hear a whole lot more said which
leads them to make a simple plea when
they talk to me
which I relate to this house with their
sincerity
don't assume or believe that everyone
attempting to enter our country
illegally is a genuine Asylum Seeker
fleeing persecution
my lords when we get to committee stage
if Noble Lord's table amendments about
the right to work for Asylum Seekers
I'll say more about why I oppose that
and I'm worried about the growing
numbers of legal migration to do
unskilled or low-skilled jobs the noble
Lord Lord Paddock was right to raise the
issue of increasing number of work study
visas of which I've also heard stories
of misuse or abuse
um there's far more to the impact of all
this than meets the eye and the noble
brownist lady Kramer who's no longer in
her place asked for evidence and I would
say to the noble lady that there's
plenty if well willing to listen
but today my lords what I ask is this
how do noble Lords opposing the
government on this bill think they are
helping genuine Asylum Seekers how does
it help improve the system
does opposing this bill help restore
people's confidence in our country's
ability to distinguish between refugees
fleeing for their lives and those who
would simply like a better life but are
willing to lie and use illegal means to
get here
does it help demonstrate we can and will
prioritize the former not the latter
does it reassure that we have the
necessary support and infrastructure to
cope with new arrivals without pitting
their needs against those of the
communities in which they're put
in short mylords how does opposing this
bill persuade the public that this house
takes seriously all their legitimate
concerns rather than ignoring them or
dismissing them as the products of
ignorance or prejudice my lords if the
lip demons divide the house tonight and
the noble Lord law Paddock has already
said he will my neighbor friendly
Minister can most definitely count on my
support my lords I support this bill
my my lab's attempting to compress all
of the My criticisms where they spill
into the time allotted would be
impossible I'm not alone in that
situation there's other Noble Lords have
indicated I know that this debate has
and I expect that it will expose
criticisms of the world's intentions its
methodology it's internal incoherence
and it's violation not only of
international law but of civilized norms
and I echo in and supportively
anticipate many of these criticisms this
bill wood is the unhcr points out
breached the UK's obligations under the
refugees the refugee convention
the 1954 convention relating to the
status of stateless persons in the 1961
convention for the reduction of
statelessness and international human
rights law and given that the Home
Secretary and the noble Lord the
minister have shared as they are obliged
to do Under The Human Rights Act their
personal View
of the compatibility of this bill with
the European Convention of Human Rights
and that they are unable to certify the
bill as incompatible with the UN
convention
I suspect that my that my normal friend
and Overlord folks of comnak who I think
um suggested yesterday that this bill's
short title is proper if the adjective
illegal was intended to qualify the noun
Bill and not migration and is accurate
this is
I'm afraid I can come to no other
conclusion a bill which is entirely
cynical in its intention it is my love
the clear case of attitudeinizing via
legislative means I don't believe that
the government of any objective for the
spill other than to create an
environment in which they can adopt a
certain posture that they think will
help their electoral
success in the future
my Lord I shall focus on two of the more
egregious measures in this bill and the
rest of my time that the Rwanda policy
is immoral has been so widely discussed
as to need no further expectation from
me although I would point out that the
latest U.S state Department Human Rights
report number one they're released six
weeks ago is even more critical than the
last for example describing typical
detention conditions in Rwanda eyes and
I quote harsh or life-threatening with
regular credible reports of unlawful or
adversary killings well as I refer back
to the debate that we had in the 9th of
December on Nucleus UK Asylum and
Refugee policy in um in in column 404 I
asked the Nova Lord the minister who
responded to that debate the following
question how do our assessments of the
robustness of the Judicial Systems the
likelihood of arbitrary arrests and the
propensity for agents of the state
to use torture and Rwanda differ from
that of the U.S state Department
I'll never forget in summing up that
debate the noble lord of the minister
willfully willfully refused to answer
questions in writing when he couldn't
get to him in his speech so he has had
five months notice of this question and
I asked him today
to explain to his your lordship's house
why the U.S state department has come to
the conclusion they have about Rwanda
and we have come to an entirely
different one what separate data do we
have that they don't
but not only am I loses this policy
immoral but as a refugee Council has
pointed out
it's French to embroil is not only in a
series of legal challenges but immense
logistical and practical Endeavors too
to put a politely record of the home
office in recent years has not been so
overwhelming and positive that I would
be confident in their ability to deal
with these expeditiously and effectively
we currently have only one existing
agreement with the country for housing a
small number of Asylum Seekers with
course 16 of our Mo you also binding us
to take a small group of Asylum Seekers
from Rwanda in return
the refugee Council estimates that and I
quote in the first three years of this
legislation coming into effect between
147 and 192 670 people will will have
had their Asylum claims deemed
inadmissible but not have been removed
they will be unable to have their Asylum
claims processed unable to work they'll
be relying on home office support and
accommodation indefinitely in total
between 8.7 billion and 9.6 billion will
have been spent on detaining and
accommodating people impacted by the
bill in the first three years of its
operation these estimates are damning
this is not reforming our Asylum system
our lives but replacing it with the
state of limbo at the immense public
expense then lastly and briefly I'd like
to raise Clause 53 Universal compliance
with internet measures issued by the
echr is critical
Last Summer the European Court of human
rights in an interim measure spilled two
British citizens from being executed by
Russia in the case of Ukraine versus
Ukraine versus Russia president zelinski
holds several interim measures against
Russia to constrain the use of military
force against civilians the whole
vitally important symbolic and practical
weight in this attempt to dilute the
powerful domestic political parties
purposes is extraordinarily
short-sighted yeah in closing I want to
make mention of the admonitory
statements of the Home Secretary and the
Secretary of State for justice and much
more importantly The Briefing on their
behalf that emerged last night they
warned that this house this house that
to oppose this bill was to constrict the
will of the people and what basis is
this numerous concept being determined
yeah again we see legitimate scrutiny
discredited by inflammatory retribute we
remember previous attempts at this with
the judges being described as enemies of
the people during brexit and the 29
election Being Framed as a context
between the British populace and their
own elective Representatives with last
night's statements of the tacit
admission that there is no argument to
be advised on defense of this bill but
it must Simply Be exceeded to we are
today in effect being asked to abdicate
our responsibilities if this bill is
objectively to our benefit what can it
stand to lose from today's proceedings
it's an honor to follow the speech of
the noble Lord Lord Brown of lady with
which I thoroughly agreed
my Lord says little mirth to be had on
the Grim subject of this shabby illegal
and immoral bill but I did allow myself
a little smile this last weekend
the chasing of easy headlines through
divisive dehumanizing and xenophobic
rhetoric about invasions by migrants and
their threat to our values did not pay
the Electoral dividend the conservatives
were hoping for despite claims that they
are the will of people in fact the
symbolic District of Dover delivered
them a big rebuff when turfing Tories
out of control in favor of Labor whom I
congratulate
and we saw an example this weekend of
how facile tough talking coupled with
Hasty headline chasing legislation
backfires at least part of the blame for
what went wrong with the Met lies with
the Home Secretary for her rushed
illiberal gesture politics legislation
if you wanted an example of how to unify
a country and bring people together in
harmony you have to look at the
coronation and the coronation concert
you certainly won't get it from the
modern conservative party and decent
stories are grasping that and not liking
it
the government has not deemed to give us
an impact assessment but the refugee
Council forecasts the forecast that
after three years of people being
refused consideration of their Asylum
claims up to 200 000 of them could
remain in this country due to the
absence of return agreements
they will be part of a whole new class
of destitute people that this bill will
knowingly create they will be in limbo
legally and socially excluded barred
from making Asylum claims but incapable
of being deported banned from working or
claiming any normal benefits excluded
from any path to settlemental
citizenship in other words an outcast
underclass that will hardly assist
cohesion
as to legal issues with this bill the
noble and learning Lord Lord Thomas of
concede has said of the proposal to
allow the government to ignore an order
from the Strasbourg Court quote many
people would say having the power to
ignore a court order is something that
unless the circumstances were quite
extraordinary is a step a government
should never take because it is symbolic
of a breach of the rule of law
legal commentator Joshua Rosenberg
Rosenberg amused is the government's new
illegal migration Bill a bill to deal
with illegal migration
or is it a migration bill that we should
regard as illegal
the lawyers who draft bills with
government departments are bound by
strict naming constraints but I wouldn't
put it past them to have slipped an
Arcane joke into the short title
the fact is that the bill does drive a
coach in horses so the UK's domestic law
and international legal obligations
including through trashing the
separation of powers and obstructing
recourse to Independent judicial
scrutiny it undermines the rule of law
in various ways not least through some
provisions of retrospective effect
the bill contravenes the refugee
convention in penalizing refugees
excluding most arrivals from the right
to seek Asylum and breaching the ban on
reform
it fails to respect the conventions as
against statelessness and the UN
convention on the rights of the child it
removes protections for victims of
trafficking and modern slavery in breach
of the European conventional engaged
trafficking and protections against
arbitrary unnecessary indefinite
detention
the bill also undermines the
universality of Human Rights contravenes
the Human Rights Act and risks breaching
the European convention on human rights
in his recent blessed to us the noble
Lord the minister said of his inability
to make a statement that the provisions
of the bill are compatible with
convention rights quote this does not
mean that the provisions in the bill are
incompatible with the convention rights
a section 191b statement simply means we
are unable to say decisively that this
bill is compatible with the echr indeed
the government is satisfied that the
provisions of the bill are capable of
being applied compatibly with those
rights should have been a scriptwriter
for Monty Python
what will the government tell next
week's Summit of 46 heads of state and
government of the Council of Europe the
first such Summit for 18 years about its
own UK contribution to fighting threat
to democracy human rights and the rule
of law when it is actually committing
such threats
everyone sensible knows that solutions
to the difficult and complex challenge
of migration pressures has to be found
not in cheap gestures and stunts and
simplistic slogans but in international
cooperation and an investment in
efficient home office administration we
could usefully seek to join Europe on as
well
to tackle the trafficking and smuggling
gags which is built does nothing about
as Financial Times commentator Gideon
rackman has written
reducing Refugee numbers in a Humane and
effective way requires a painstaking
combination of diplomacy law enforcement
and targeted development deportations
and walls make better headlines but
worse policy
would that this government were to take
note of such wise counsel and finally as
the rebukes of the noble Lords Lord fast
Forsyth and Dobbs none of whom are now
in their place have no Tory Pierce ever
voted against the bill at second reading
I look forward to finding out yeah
committee on human rights on which I
serve is required and mandated by
Parliament to scrutinize every
government bill for its compatibility
with human rights but my Lord how is it
expected to do that if a Home Secretary
fails to come to the committee and to
defend and explain a bill that she's
been unable to sign off as human rights
compliant discourteous and worse by
contrast in 2015 and with consummate
skill Theresa May steered The Landmark
modern-day slavery and human trafficking
legislation through Parliament providing
pre-legislative scrutiny and building
bipartisan and bicameral consensus and
support last week with my Noble and
learned friend lady Butler Sloss and the
noble Lord Lord McCall of dulwich we
spent an hour with Lady May and three
and Duncan Smith and I hope that when
the noble Lord the minister comes to
reply he'll explain why their Amendment
on victims of trafficking and I think
alluded to by the Nobel Lord Lord
Forsyth in his remarks has not been
accepted let's be clear the changes
proposed in the bill will not stop the
votes as modern slavery victims are just
six percent of small boats arrivals but
it will remove support and protection
from many genuine victims it will deter
slavery victims exploited on British
soil from coming forward and leaving
them trapped in exploitation and making
Prosecuting criminal gangs even harder
my lords I've been a trustee of a
charity that combats trafficking and
yesterday chaired a session for key
organizations including the Salvation
Army who with Partners have supported
over 18
000 victims during the 11 years they
have held the government's modern
slavery victim care contract they point
out that the bill disapplies various
protections and those who arrive
irregularly and indirectly will be
deemed a quotes threat to public order
and will therefore be disqualified from
the existing legal protections now the
weight of evidence received by The Joint
Committee for human rights some of it I
might say taken in camera from victims
has been overwhelmingly clear that this
would be in breach of the UK's
obligations under the Council of
Europe's convention against trafficking
and Article 4 of the European convention
on human rights yesterday at that
meeting with the Salvation Army I was
told that traffickers will use the new
law as a tool but it won't break the
cycle of exploitation only exacerbate it
adding to the trauma to destitution to
homelessness mental illness to people
living outside the law in precarious
uncertainty paradoxically my lords will
Empower traffickers and brothel owners
and disempower the victims the jchr also
heard concerns that Clauses two to five
will ultimately lead to the UK failing
to play its part in the global system of
refugee protection a theme that has been
mentioned so often in the debate so far
Vicki Tennant UK representative to the
United Nations Refugee agency told the
committee of the bill is I quote a
series of unilateral measures that are
about pushing refugees away and pushing
responsibility onto other countries it
will undermine the Trust In Regional
cooperation needed to manage these
movements within the last 24 hours unhcr
said this it breaks the core un
conventions the unhcr is mandated to
safeguard the 1951 Refugee convention
and the 1954 statelessness convention in
addition to concerns for the victims of
trafficking there are five other areas
that have raised red flags for the jchr
one the removal of protections for
refugees and stateless persons two
potential for indefinite and arbitrary
detention three due process and appeal
rights
uh being compromised for concerns over
interim measures completely and lack of
protections for both accompanied and
unaccompanied children a point of course
properly made by the noble Lord Lord
dubs whose Amendment on children I
seconded when it was considered and
supported right across your lordship's
house the jchr heard that the bill would
not be compatible with the UK's
obligations under both the echr and the
UN convention on the rights of the child
two experts said the provision quotes
creates risks of Article 5 breaches
while Welsh women's aides said they
would inevitably be quote an increase in
the number of women and children
exploited in Hidden and organized in
illegal trade as far as due process and
appeal rights is concerned isn't a
freedom of torture who told us that I
quote a person may be able to provide
reasonable or even strong evidence but
not quite enough to be compelling very
many refugees they say will not be able
to surmount this evidential burden
putting them at risk of harm
my lords the bill also gives ministers
legislative permission to ignore interim
measures indicated by the European Court
of Human Rights and to breach various
International and domestic legal
obligations and risks breaching others
several witnesses told us that the bill
is so bad it's simply incapable of
amendment and that we should undertake
post-legis scrutiny first of the
nationality and board of act which only
came into force in January before
legislating further if it proves
impossible to amend this bill in the
ways that many noble Lords have argued
during the course of this debate then we
should have no hesitation of using our
constitutional right to defeat it at
third reading but my lords I agree with
others in saying that it is our duty to
consider this bill at committee and
Report let me end in 1938 the
independent MP Eleanor Rathbone
established a parliamentary committee on
refugees in 1940 during a 6 our debate
when Europe faced the challenge of
enormous numbers of displaced people she
argued that in addition to the
humanitarian case they were hard-headed
reasons for the UK to lead the
international response she said it's not
only in the interest of humanity and of
refugees but in the interests of
security itself Her speech and its
description of dog whistle politics and
the stigmatization of refugees Bears
careful study today
my Lord so I beg to move that the house
to adjourn during pleasure until 3 pm
now the question is that the debate on
the illegal migration bill will be
adjourned until after all questions as
many as that opinion will say content
the country not content the contents
habit